do you uh you know I I think that
there's something to be said like
anybody who's in a leadership
uh role I feel like a lot of people
depend on you
um you're a young leader in hip-hop but
it just in terms of just your life your
life your personal spiritual life
everybody 100 everyone's looking at you
every single person in my life depends
on me whether it's financially whether
it's leadership emotional whatever it is
opportunity emotional everybody in my
life depends on me for something you
know I'm saying I depend on them for
things too of course but it's a
double-sided relationship you know what
I'm saying but I have the most
responsibility so I gotta carry myself
that way you know so I can't take
nothing personal I gotta go and get this
[ __ ] because life is not a promise so
I'm here I'm Gonna Get Where I Wanna Be
and I'm going to put the people who I
want to put in position in position I'm
not going to take it personal I'm not
going to take a day off I'm not going to
waste a day right this [ __ ] could be
taken from me tomorrow 100 I can't win
more than one way it could be taken from
you bro